all right so families at the hospital
sitting around the deathbed at a grand
day it's really sad because the
granddad's only 38 he had an asthma
attack during the whip and then a with
your two bitches he met on tinder one
nun was pregnant which we didn't know
how because he hid yeah anyway everybody
says send their last goodbyes
I'm Betty comes up a tried to do her
last goodbye she got some big-ass
titties a little bitty tank top some
Baywatch cuz they get hot in Flint
next thing you know she leans over to
kiss him on the forehead saying goodbye
but the titty greatest live
he takes good day what's that pair
lotion lotion pure flavor lotion they
say you know his dick start rising up
he getting an erection underneath the
sheets then he flatlined dude it wasn't
two beeps I just can't do a whole flat
next thing you know the car around pops
up viagra granddaddy did but that decade